[Musique]
les énarques se dévergonde une
quarantaine d'élèves a passé la nuit
dans les locaux de la célèbre école
nationale d'administration ils
protestent contre le déménagement de
l'ena à strasbourg les futurs cadres de
l'état se rebelle contre l'autorité de
l'état reportage jean-jacques bazié
antoine off
ils s'y sentent tellement bien dans leur
école parisienne de la rue de
l'université qui n'ont plus envie de la
quitter même la nuit pense pas qu'un
jour j'aurai l'honneur de me coucher sur
la moquette l'amphithéâtre jean moulin
message c'est de montrer malgré son que
loin d'être coupée la réalité sociale de
ce pays nous pouvions voir des prêts que
des préoccupations theater
terre-à-terre certes mais aussi une
excellente opération de promotion de
l'école par leurs différentes
initiatives de ces derniers jours les
élèves de l'ena en réussi à donner une
image différente de celle qui leur colle
à la peau celle de jeunes austère triste
coupé des réalités du monde
sinon il serait qu'on n'est pas les
polars en cravate et henri stoll mec
nous reconnaissons qu au train de
croiser dans la rue nous sommes des
hommes et des femmes comme tout le monde
comme disait ma camarade les élèves qui
ont un père une mère j'espère que tout
le monde en est conscient et tout ce que
vous direz soir oui oui je voudrais tu
dois revenir
[Musique]